the strip gets ready to reopen and more
testing takes place the question is now
how will our industry recover today the
Las Vegas Convention and Visitors
Authority approved its budget for the
next year and it's a bit of a glimpse
into the damage that's already been done
Bianca Holman here joining us with a
closer look Bianca afternoon the call
was very brief the budget presented at
this morning was unchanged from what it
was presented before at the previous
board meeting so the budget was approved
fairly quickly now much of the revenue
generated for the lv CVA comes from
hotel room tax but with casinos closed
in late March the authority had to make
immediate at adjustments slashing
seventy nine million dollars from its
2020 2021 budget it had been projecting
about three hundred million dollars in
broome tax revenue this year now it's
expecting a third of that approximately
80 positions of the 455 full-time
workforce have been eliminated lv cba
executives also took a pay cut and
bonuses suspended there was a public
comment suggesting the agency focus on
attracting smaller meetings which would
help bring about confidence to tourists
that Vegas is okay a healthy and safe
place for business now the budget was
approved by all over the phone recording
Bianca Holman 8:00 news now